the PlayStation 3 has come a long way
especially in America Sony's console was
the sales frontrunner across Europe in
Japan but Microsoft always dominated the
US but those numbers have recently
started to even out Microsoft still has
the advantage in the US but they're
neck-and-neck worldwide with over 80
million consoles sold across the entire
world the reason for Playstations
comeback is how they've improved their
online capabilities and started offering
exclusive content that people really
want to play first off just take a look
at the library the ps3 offers an almost
unrivaled variety of content including
almost every major triple-a release from
last years and years previous grand
theft auto 5 tomb raider BioShock
Infinite battlefield 4 Call of Duty
ghosts basically if it was released on
multiple platforms one of those
platforms was the ps3 but Sony comes out
on top because the massive slate of
exclusive titles from their own stable
of Studios Naughty Dog's
Uncharted series set the bar for what an
adventure game could be and they
followed it up with the powerfully
moving story in The Last of Us the Metal
Gear Solid series may have some divisive
entries but almost everyone can agree
that the ps3 exclusive Metal Gear Solid
4 is one of the best journey in Flour
two independent games from that game
company push the boundaries of how to
interact with a game and tell a unique
story without using any words at all
Dark Souls may be all the rage now but
it started with the ps3 exclusive demon
souls which you can pick up for a
ridiculously cheap as part of the
PlayStation greatest hits collection the
family-friendly LittleBigPlanet put
creation directly in the hands of
players letting them make levels using
the same tools the developers had access
to and that's not even touching on the
dozens of other critical and commercial
successes Sony has had and that success
is going to carry through 2014 and
beyond most multi-platform games are
still slated to get ps3 releases the
brutally funny South Park and the stick
of truth the brutally difficult Dark
Souls 2 the enigmatic Metal Gear Solid 5
Ground zeroes and plus one of the most
anticipated games across pretty much
every platform watch
but I haven't touched on the consoles
biggest selling point PlayStation Plus
unlike the ps4 and Microsoft's consoles
multiplayer and access to most of the
system's online capabilities comes at no
additional charge but the reasonably
priced PlayStation Plus subscription
introduces cloud game saving deep
discounts in the PlayStation Network
store each month and most importantly
three games every month so if you're on
the fence about upgrading to a next-gen
console the PlayStation offers every
excuse to wait
there's plenty to play until the
next-gen consoles fall in price sometime
next year and by then there will also be
a lot more titles announced as next-gen
exclusives but 2015 is still a long way
away